welcome to this video playing
International Master argon took
what is the name the yantan Das from
India okay let's play the sawian
let's see going for for a C3 setup
okay yeah I can transpose to some sort
of French with E5 or take yeah I guess
I'm going to take
okay
so you takes with the queen yeah why not
one of the main lines of the C Series C3
Sicilian complex
um okay
hmm I guess I cannot take right
can I just develop here and I'm not sure
about it
I could have played C4 Maybe
okay
um okay I have Knight C3 next
if he goes
he can play night before but it
shouldn't be a huge issue
I just play Bishop E2
yeah that still feels like a very normal
position
with an iqp
let's get this usual battery going with
Queen D3
do I go Rook T1 yes I guess with D5 yeah
D5 is a key idea
that should
be supported
um
um if I go Bishop G5 now
is what he's doing what G6
hmm okay
then D5 Ed
takes 95
that's some initiative but probably not
sufficient I I probably should switch to
this diagonal
to increase the
pressure here with the D5 push this is
some quite a problem for black
I think it is
something like Bishop G7 D5 ed5 Knight
D5 is um
potential pressure
not easy to that it's not easy to fight
okay yeah that's an interesting question
now
um can I
I can also take which is interesting
and then D5
huh
D5 takes Knight takes
I have those those funny ideas with the
pressure on G6
but I think this persists even if I just
Retreat it
so I'm not sure wow
really
okay
yeah maybe you can do that it looks very
shaky
I don't think I could have sacrificed I
don't really
believe that but
this is a very risky way to play okay he
wants to play Knight D5 to to block
to block things
okay
I need to need to
get something going here against against
the king
I can also switch back my Bishop to B1
if I want
um yeah here I can actually just take F7
now
let's just check that I'm not
overlooking something stupid I don't
think so
Queen F5
the bishop on A2 is always exerting very
useful pressure
yeah it's funny he hasn't he cannot he
must take yeah I mean the queen has has
really no squares
at least this is what I think
okay so much for the queen has no
squares
um can I take F5 actually is this a
possibility
F5
Queen D1 Rook D1 EF
can give a discovered check
and I'm winning B7 at the end hmm
that's definitely not bad let's let's do
it
maybe I had something simpler
yeah he has to take
has to take um
D1
uh wait I can also take with the Knight
EF
96 check
it's not really helping him
do that
this was my original intention
wanting to take B7 which gives me two
pieces for a rook
and still a nice position if I take here
though let's
check this briefly I'm probably not
helping
the only thing that is a bit irritating
is the smooth Bishop A3
but I have Knight D6 I guess hmm
yeah f96
wow it's allowing this check
on Knight D6 so this is
this is probably a good idea
takes
Bishop takes
he cannot really initiate a dangerous
pinning situation
Bishop F7 also would have been
interesting here
played this a bit too quickly
yeah but it's it should be winning in
any case to be honest
okay so Bishop somewhere
Rook C6 is a possibility time warning
how do I coordinate the pieces
Maybe
hmm
Bishop 5 is not very nice
maybe this bishop E5 then
it's not a super great coordination
really
okay now that that should be enough
check
just don't stumble into any any stupid
Checkmate yeah
check
foreign
black resigns
okay that was a really messy game at
some point I'm not sure about it
but I really cannot believe some of
Black's moves here
let's see G6 Bishop A2 is right I guess
and here there's an in first interesting
moment I was thinking that this is also
interesting
because after D5 if he takes now
um there's always this possibility if
you just for one moment if you consider
this and let's say he plays a move like
that I can take
this was an idea all night takes but I
wasn't really sure what to do if he just
placed this for example I mean I just
have to move this Knight and take on G6
but there is really no way to do it with
a Tempo or
any Force for move here you can just
take with the Knight and cover G6
so this is why I went with Bishop H4 at
the end and now he's got this this funny
G5 business
okay I intended uh to open up the whole
situation and now we went here yeah
Knight F7 is just strong but maybe here
I have something better even
I have something better the computer is
merciless this is just very strong
yeah now this is something I should have
seen actually consider the most forcing
moves yeah Bishop takes Queen takes is
very very simple
and Knight takes I go here and then I
can take the queen next I just would
have won immediately
check this also wins but it takes
considerably longer and you can of
course still
screw it up I hope I didn't
um it felt like I had things under
controller
yeah you can some improve on some of
those moves but important is not to
allow any any stupid stuff
like this checkmate
yeah and check check yeah I'm
controlling things nicely oh yeah here
could have won The Rook but is this a
win in any case so shouldn't be too
too critical about it okay I hope you
enjoyed this thanks for watching